I don't think that the questions that I
ask are that personal it is a time for
them to maybe put the record straight it
works both ways some people say I don't
want to do the you know do the show
because I may have to reveal myself
others say you know what it's about time
that I can tell it the way it is Barbara
was as much a celebrity as any of the
countless Stars She interviewed
hey solo already solos did you know you
were good looking the truth audiences
first got to know her in 1961 when she
debuted as a reporter on NBC's today
there was an awful lot of noise made
over not too much we had a producer once
who said that people get up in the
morning and they switch on that dial to
find out if the world is still there and
I think I felt that but I must point out
that I had no thought of being on the
program I always thought I would just be
a writer that just happened I never
expected it she eventually was made
co-host and was lured away in 1976 to
co-anchor ABC's evening news with
veteran newsman Harry Reasoner I have a
new colleague to welcome Barbara
thank you Harry
well tonight has finally come for me and
I'm very pleased to be with you Harry
and with ABC News and later I'll have a
chance to comment on my new duties but
at the time she was criticized for her
reported one million dollar salary and
many were not ready for a woman in such
a high profile spot when I left NBC and
came to ABC that first year or two
was so difficult for me I really felt
that I was drowning that my career was
over I and I had to work and I wanted to
work and I I couldn't see my way out of
it she worked her way out becoming a
co-anchor of 2020 and hosting her
celebrity specials Walters did more than
a hundred interviews with ET over nearly
40 years and was there to induct us into
the museum of TV and radio well I think
Entertainment Tonight is unique I mean
it really was the first program that
made entertainment news and I have to
admit even though I'm going to be sorry
I did that I very often use the
Entertainment Tonight interviews as
homework for my interviews Hello I'm
Barbara's signature way of speaking with
a lisp was parodied for years on SNL and
the legend once stopped by Weekend
Update to poke fun at herself what an
honor it was to see my groundbreaking
career in journalism reduced to a
cartoon character with a ridiculous
voice
he launched The View in 1997 we were
there from the very beginning this is
not a sleazy show this is a show that
we'll have a celebrity guest the kind of
coffee clutch that you would have with
your own Pals at home except all of us
of different ages and different
backgrounds Rosie O'Donnell joined the
show in 2006 At first she and Barbara
seemed to have a great relationship we
knew this was going to be okay and we
knew that it was going to be fun and we
are going to have days when we disagree
that's what it's all about this is the
most honest person what you see on
camera is what you see off camera so
it's going to be a good time but one
year later there was a falling out Rosie
left amidst reports of a feud with
Walters Rosie is now saying that her
biggest problem with the view is that
she should have been in charge but when
we first talked to Rosie she didn't want
that she said no I want to just be one
of the members of it as it turns out
that's not what she wanted she wanted to
be Diana Ross with the rest of us in the
chorus and that's was very difficult for
her Barbara also made headlines when she
released her autobiography in 2008 she
revealed a secret affair in the 1970s
with Senator Edward Brooke people
consider me such a prig I think that
they were very surprised of this
Revelation and he was not only
African-American but married I knew that
it was beginning to leak out people in
Washington were talking about it and it
was then that that we thought this was
something that had to end
it could harm us both always healthy
with Boundless Energy in 2010 she
addressed her audience about a heart
problem later this week I'm going to
have surgery to replace one faulty heart
valve four years later at age 84 Walters
stepped away from hosting the view I'm
going to have to learn to live another
kind of life too to enjoy things to take
time to travel Oprah who said her career
was inspired by Barbara appeared on her
last show please welcome Diane Sawyer
Robin Roberts and surprised her with
other famous female TV journalists who
had followed in her footsteps I've got
to go sometime I want to go now while
things are good while I'm still doing
stories while I'm still in good health
you know a few years back I had a big
heart problem you know I survived I'm
here Walters was a woman who knew her
place in the history of broadcasting but
said her rise to fame came through hard
work my cup run is over I thank you
thank you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]